welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul i never say nevers as
we're back with our breakdown for the
show's finale
i know i stopped covering this because
of other commitments but i have been
watching it week to week and so far i've
really really enjoyed it
the six episode season set in an
alternate victorian london
follows the touched as they attempted to
break free of the stigma centered around
them
and their incredible abilities
unfortunately this was easier said than
done
as a touched killer called malady
started to commit crimes in the capital
it was up to our main cast of characters
including frank mundy
amalia true and penanced air to get here
and after the good detective managed to
bring her in
episode 5 saw her being sentenced to
death there's also been a plotline
involving lord massen
who we discovered was behind the
assassination of one of the touched
named mary
madison had taken her out as she had the
ability to reach out and
uplift the touched but this backfired as
her death rallied more of them together
we ended episode 5 with malady's public
hanging but there was a twist when we
saw that one of her shoes fell off
to reveal she had some missing toes if
you cast your mind back to earlier in
the season
then you may remember that there was
someone devoted to malady who did this
and she indeed gave her own life in one
final act
it turned out that melody had been
posing as effie boyle
who was actually the girl that turned up
dead at the start of the season
malady revealed that this execution was
all part of her plan to kill members of
the public
and using electricity and her assistant
several of them were taken out
that sort of takes us to the finale of
season one and in it we discover the
true identity of amalia
it turns out that the character was
originally a woman named molly
who used to be a baker's apprentice she
was in love with a man named varnam
who wasn't ready to get married and
after she was demoted at work
she was left with no other option than
to marry a man named mr true
who's what would happen if this channel
was a person
wait now molly sadly suffered with
several miscarriages
and was forced to work as a delivery
woman for the bakery for next to no
money
after true died molly was left to care
for his bedridden mother
and this left her as a widow with no
money or enjoyment in life
it's super depressing and watching her
travel down the alleyway
day after day knowing that varnam is
with someone else
is really heartbreaking after leaving a
note for varnam
one day instead of going left down the
alley she decides to go right
and as we know molly ended up jumping
into the thames
it was during this moment that the
galanti arrived she was taken over by a
character called stripe
played by claudia black who came from
the future and i can't believe
we actually got this fan theory right
all the way back in our episode one
breakdown
[Music]
you best believe that mephisto is coming
soon i'm telling you now in this entry
we learn a lot about stripe
and the backstory of the galanti which
are so mysterious that even most of the
actors in the show
don't know how to pronounce it i
probably butchered it too but the clues
were there including true saying that
amalia wasn't her true face
we also caught her looking into the
mirror more than perseus
sometimes the jokes aren't good she also
terrible she also had the great skills
and abilities
and the fact that her character died
just as the aliens arrived
sort of tipped its hat to the twist the
theme of switching and fake identities
was of course
also seen in melody's reveal and i like
this idea of both the good and bad
not being all that they seem now i don't
know if people found the twist
all that mind-blowing or if they guessed
it early on but whether i've found it
predictable or not
there was still a lot of mystery in the
alien race
so i did like that the show made you
feel like you could see into the future
much like true whilst also managed to
keep some surprises
now we discovered that the galanti are
an incredibly powerful alien race
who traveled to our planet far into the
future through portals
using spores they were able to give
members of the public special abilities
and those touched by the galanti were
able to understand their tech
this meant that certain members of
society were far more advanced than
others
and it caused a lot of conflict episode
6 opens not in victorian london
but far in the future which we learn is
in the midst of a civil war
humanity is divided on the galanti and
while some believe they are there for
good
others are fearful and hate the race
this episode is divided into several
chapters
with the first being titled stripe this
chronicles the conflict between the
extremists known as free life
and the pdc which stands for the
planetary defense coalition
we follow stripe as she comes across
someone who has been touched by the
galanti
and the pair discussed several aspects
of their world after they exchanged
gunfire and managed to capture one of
the free life
they search a deserted outpost which we
discover held one of the galanti
here a pdc scientist loved the alien and
took care of it
the pair discover many of his things
including an obsession with victorian
london
which of course ties into the general
plot of the show i had to watch this
chapter twice as picking up here
was very jarring and much like us
striper's difficulty
keeping a grasp of her reality because
of the self-medication she has subjected
herself to
the character suffers from ptsd and den
of geek recently dropped an interview
with laura donnelly
discussing everything that we need to
know about her donnelly said she had
difficulty keeping a lid on things when
the season first launched
and that she simply stuck to saying that
she was playing a victorian woman
instead of the war hardened combat-ready
one who fought in a planetary warfare in
the future
we also get an indication that she is
amalia as the character puts her fingers
to her thumb as she's being treated
which is one of her many mannerisms the
ptsd moment she suffers from
also give her flashbacks which are sort
of a reworking of the flash forwards
that amalia gets
we learned that knitter is the other of
the two and she was initially part of
the free life however after she was
spored
she changed sights along with the rest
of the group they worked their way
through the base
until they discover one of the galanti
the free life
that captured the base didn't have the
ability to kill it and thus instead they
tortured it by killing
everyone there that it cared about we
learned that it's opened a portal that
could potentially allow more of the
galanti to travel to earth
and the group have a tough choice to
make many worry that the galanti will
return with even more of their forces to
level the planet
which leads to one of the members
swapping sites
he frees the captive and also shoots
knitter stripe kills him
and after knitter dies in front of her
she journeys to the medical bay to end
her own life
she decides that enough is enough and
drinks two bottles of lethal liquid
however just as she's about to die the
galanthi embraces her
and carries her spirit with it we
discover that it didn't open the portal
to bring more forces in
but rather it wanted a means of escape
and together the two travel into the
past
this is where she bonded with molly
whose backstory makes up the second
chapter in the episode
now if you're enjoying the video i'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up
and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
from here chapter 3 follows stripe now
occupying her body
and she's taken to an asylum believing
that it's all a simulation
now sporting an american accent and
seeing the future
she meets sarah who we know goes under
become melody
it's not too long before she also meets
the doctor at the asylum
who we learn is horatio cousins she
realizes that he's one of the touched
and the pair start having an affair
after she divulges her true identity
she learns that unlike in her time the
victorian sport have superpowers
rather than simply being able to
understand the galanti tech
one day dr hague arrives to study the
touched and amalia
lies about what's really going on with
her unfortunately she throws sarah under
the bus
and this of course has repercussions for
the future amalia realizes that there
are nefarious forces out there that will
attempt to use her
and that she must bury the truth she
starts putting on an english accent
and learns etiquette lessons from
another patient in order to fly under
the radar
she readies her body for the incoming
fight and also starts to collect weapons
during a hearing for her freedom these
are discovered and amalia ends up being
locked in a padded cell
this is where lavinia bidlow arrives and
she ends up making her the head of her
orphanage
from here we jump to the final chapter
titled true which picks up at the same
time that melody is apparently being
hanged
amalia and koa excavating an underground
site in order to find the galanti
and after she falls into one of its
cavernous tunnels
she discovers where dr hague had been
carrying out his research
much like how it was in the future the
galanthi is trapped in the ceiling
and it now has several harpoons pointed
at it amalia feels like she's very much
been left in the dark by the creature
but after putting her hand on its
chamber she receives a vision
this shows both her life and molly's and
we also catch a vision in which she
tells penance about who she is
and how grim the future is however
penance is confident that they can
change it
and this is likely the reason that
stripe was brought back the future isn't
said
and as we know from our history the
touch didn't exist in victorian london
thus their intervention could alter the
future significantly
and it's clear that the series will be
about averting a war
however they could also now have
inadvertently created one
as the government of course greatly fear
they touched and are putting things in
place in order to cause chaos
in the vision we also hear a voice
saying that amalia isn't the only person
that's there from the future i'd
obviously love to hear who you think
this is
but i personally believe that it could
be hague he knows a lot about the
touched
and may even be a member of the free
life however it could also be myrtle who
we do see in this vision
myrtle is able to speak almost every
language imaginable
and as we learn from knitter in the
future the sports powers are more
language based
we also know that she understood what
mary's song truly meant
so it is possible that she's just
another vessel sent back to translate
their messages
there's definitely a number of people it
could be and probably not even any of
these ones i've listed
so yeah let me know below exactly what
you think a hague's forces arrive
and amalia manages to escape through an
elevator which is lifted by elizabeth
who you may remember was one of the
doctor's victims
the season ends with the malia saying
the touchdown gonna have to prepare for
war
and she finally gives her a true name
which is zephyr
we watch as a prototype zeppelin flies
over the orphanage
and in the season wondering what's to
come zephyr itself
means a light wind which could be
carrying this
and yeah that's a reach now as for my
thoughts on this series as a whole
i think that it's a bit of a weird one
to judge obviously there's a lot of
controversy surrounding it because of
joss whedon
and behind the scenes we know that it's
gonna be a while before we see the
property again
philippa gosling is currently being
tapped to replace whedon
but because of the pandemic and
so-called changing of the god
the earliest we can expect to see the
show's return is 2023
i am optimistic that the series will
continue
and they definitely saved the best for
last this was easily
head and shoulders above the rest of
season one for me and
i think anyone who watches this will be
very excited for season two
i definitely think that there's a lot
here people will enjoy and there's some
great twists and turns in the series as
a whole
unfortunately judging it as a whole i do
feel like there's a lot of spinning
plates too
now the touches are of course what i was
really interested in
and whenever we're following true or
melody i think the season really show
what it could be
there was a lot to like there and i
think that if they had a focus
more on those moments it would have
sorted out the pacing issues too
i think they should have just been where
we spent our time and a lot of the side
stories and subplots
just didn't really work for me the
finale was great because it focused on
the story and giving us answers
i just wish that it didn't take so long
for us to get there
so i do think that there is potential
for something to be done here
and the show will continue to get better
and better i'm optimistic that this
might even become one of hbo's great
series
as there's definitely more good than
there is bad
i really enjoyed this finale and though
some of the episodes leading up to it
were a bit hit and miss
i think i i think i do like the nevers
yeah i will be back
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on it and your theories as well
so make sure you comment below and let
me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of may in which we're
giving away three copies of the godzilla
versus kong collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the series
the winners of last month's competition
or on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
love death and robot season 2 which will
be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the ending of all our
episodes and discussed what we took from
them
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more by the way thank
you for clicking this
i've been paul you've been the best and
i'll see you next time take care
peace